il y a un an le soir de la fête de la
musique steve mailhac à nice au 24 ans
disparaît sans laisser de traces après
une intervention musclée de la police
sur le quai wilson à nantes mort noyé
son corps avait été retrouvé dans la
loire plus d'un mois après les faits
steve maya can i saw est devenu un
symbole dans cette ville où tag
inscriptions et peinture avec le slogan
justice pour steve restent visibles un
peu partout
souvenez-vous l'année dernière nous
étions allés à nantes rencontrer ses
proches qu'il n'avait aucune nouvelle de
lui
ils nous ont raconté cette soirée où
tout a basculé regarder bas à la police
ils sont venus se sont garés est la
dernière où on voit les travaux se sont
garés les phares vers là et ils sont
sortis ils ont se sont mis en ligne à
peu près là où il ya le poteau
électrique
ils ont commencé à avancer jusqu à peu
près l'herbe qu'on voit là ils ont
chargé une première fois et après un peu
plus tard une deuxième fois mais j'ai eu
plein de panique tentant d des gens
crier et pleurer tu as des gens qui
créent et qui voyait rien mais c'était
horrible pour marquer le premier
anniversaire de la disparition de steve
une marche blanche est organisée à
nantes elle les initiateurs souhaitent
profiter de cet événement pour dénoncer
les violences policières
le rendez vous est donné devant la
préfecture de la ville pour ensuite
rejoindre le quai wilson
le préfet a édicté des consignes
strictes
la marche est autorisée mais pas la
manifestation non-déclarée prévu le jour
même
côté judiciaire malgré une enquête qui
avance très lentement un an après la
mort de steve des zones d'ombré
subsistent plusieurs témoins explique
avoir été aveuglé par un nuage de gaz
lacrymogène 15 personnes était tombé
dans le fleuve dont steve pour le moment
aucune mise en examen a été annoncée à
la fin du mois de mai l' affaire avait
été transféré de l'igpn 1
juge d'instruction indépendant alors
qu'une information judiciaire contre x
pour homicide involontaire est ouverte
depuis l'été 2010 9
le procureur de la république de rennes
philippe astruc a récemment tenu à
préciser que trois informations
judiciaires au total sont en cours selon
ce dernier
l'ensemble des expertises techniques
devraient fournir des informations et
faire la lumière sur cette soirée
elles viendront compléter les nombreux
témoignages déjà recueillis par le
parquet de nantes est la famille du
jeune homme devrait donc être reçus par
le magistrat instructeur